welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and I am vengeance
I am the knight I whoa every week same
bat-time same bat-channel we go over the
biggest news on the upcoming Matt Reeves
movie and this video we're going to be
wrapping everything up we know from the
bat bike scenes that were shot over the
weekend filming for these scenes has now
officially finished and there's actually
a lot that we can take from them we're
gonna be discussing the plot reveals the
characters that showed up and a lot more
we're also gonna be going over a leaked
image of the film that has since been
removed by Warner Brothers we can't show
it as videos are getting DMC aid left
right and center but I'll be discussing
what's in it and why it's important
there will be some spoilers here so if
you don't want anything about the film
rune then I highly suggest that you turn
off now without the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking the
video now let's get into our breakdown
of the Batman okay so Friday got off to
a falling start with our first look at
bike man and all Abbas armor in full
view now I did see a lot of people
saying that the suit looked pretty crap
but this is a stunt suit and oftentimes
on films this is built in a same way
when putting a stunt suit together they
use less expensive materials because one
it will probably get damaged and two
it's made to be more maneuverable this
is common across the board in films and
even Daniel Craig has two different
suits in Bond movies he uses a tighter
one for when he's standing still which
makes him look more muscular and another
larger one for when he's running that
helps him to move a lot better this is
the case here and you may also notice
that the Cape is missing this is after
the case as it can get caught in
spinning wheels and reps someone's head
off so it's probably going to be CGI'd
in there was glass used on the cowl at
several points but I think this was put
in place more to protect the riders eyes
they may be doing the white eyes as we
haven't really seen anything beyond the
camera test right now but it is more
likely that these will be taken out as
we saw the suit without them
as for the gauntlets these seem to pull
from ancient Japanese armor as we know
from Bruce Wayne's origin story he
travelled around the world
training in order to become the Batman
Japan was on the checklist and in Batman
89 a suit from there appear to the
gauntlets seem to have dots on them that
could potentially be fired or perhaps
even contain his grapple I'm not sure on
that though I'm just saying what I've
seen theorized online that also looks to
be a watch which could be used for
communications displaying Holograms and
a lot more Batman love's calling about
Fred in the middle of the night to make
sure he's got some some itches therefore
when he gets back to the cave and who
knows if the movie is successful that
this could even provide a direct line to
Oracle there's also a doll like shooting
device underneath and this could be used
for shooting smoke pellets obviously
these are all fan theories but it does
show that the Batman is very well
equipped now personally I believe that
this is a prototype suit and that these
may even be the precursor to the
Batarang I do still think that the chest
symbol is detachable and then it could
be used by Batman but it's rare he uses
darts and I think these will more likely
be upgraded over time the influences in
the suit pull from a lot of comics
including Gotham by Gaslight for the
cowl the wrist plates look very similar
to a court of owls Talon which you can
see here look very similar and Batman
awell has definitely been used for the
chess piece there's a ton of other
things mixed in there such as Arkham
Knight but these are the main ones so
that's pretty much the suit and
everything that I've noticed in it now
as for the scene yeah a lot was going on
Glasgow itself was turned into Gotham
City with all of the road signs in the
area being changed in swap round to
display things that you would tend to
see in the good ol US of A the attention
to detail was phenomenal with license
plates and cars being swapped out too
and the production team turned over
everything that he could in order to
make this a living breathing Gotham now
as for the chase it started off very
badass in a cemetery and then went into
the streets of the city itself in order
to talk about what I think happens in it
I'm gonna have to discuss the long
Halloween which I think teases a lot of
what's going on so the book opens with a
wedding hosted by carmine Falcone and
which he tries to get Bruce on board
with his schemes the billionaire playboy
rejects this and later that night he
breaks into his penthouse to find out
what's going on he finds Catwoman there
who - is trying to find out some
thing is too big of a secret to drop in
this video he puts a bounty on
Catwoman's head and Batman also chases
her through the city before she manages
to escape in the behind-the-scenes
images we see a woman who is the same
height in builders zoe kravitz
riding a motorbike and Batman was
definitely chasing her I think that in
this scene Catwoman has stolen something
from Falcone and Batman is chasing her
in an attempt to get it now there were
also other bikes that joined the chase
and this could be part of penguins gang
who may be in cahoots with Falcone all
of the crime families in Gotham tend to
have a truce with one another so it
makes sense that penguin would send his
best men after Catwoman Catwoman is of
course a master thief and the fact that
Batman was chasing her as well as the
gang members makes me think that there's
definitely a lot of weight to the theory
she doesn't have a cat get up yet so I
think that this is very early in the
story when she's just starting out the
chase scene 2 happens right at the start
of the graphic novel so it is definitely
possible that this opens up the movie
with a big action scene that introduces
the characters and what the dynamics of
the city are like there's a funeral
early on in the book too so it is
possible that it could all tie into that
this chase may even be the first meeting
of the two characters and if it is I
think it's the perfect way to kick-start
their relationship now before we get
into the rest of the video I just want
to let you know we're giving away a free
copy of the nfinity saga box set to one
random subscriber all you have to do to
be in with a chance of winning is like
the video subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on the updates in
the comment section below but when it's
gonna be chosen at random on the 15th of
March in the set will be shipped out
from then - ever gets the prize so best
of luck to everyone he takes part anyway
with all of that out the way we also had
a leaked image of the movie that
appeared on reddit over the weekend the
image has since been removed and all
reposts of it have been taken down by
Warner Brothers
typically this tends to be enforced when
things are legitimate and it recently
also happened with the case of the
Wonder Woman 1984 cheetah poster now we
can't confirm if this is in the movie
until we see it but there wasn't that
much in it but just in case you were
wondering I did see it and that looked
pretty gruesome basically there was a
dead man in a suit sat in a chair with a
transparent bag
for his head it looked like he'd been
suffocated and from what I remember
there was blood on the bag as well now
what made this so interesting is that it
was reportedly a victim of the Riddler
and there were the classic question
marks that the character tends to leave
at the scene of a crime flowing around
behind him these were black from what I
remember but the image was quite low
quality and was taken on a cell phone so
it's possible that they are dark green
or just plain green now the reason I
didn't report on it is because it looked
fake but the fact that Warner Brothers
are taking it down
does bank it seemed more real now if it
is real why this is interesting is
because the long Halloween centers
around a killer that strikes on certain
holidays in the book it's revealed to be
one of the PAL counties but they may
have switched it up for the movie with
the killer being the Riddler he is of
course one of the more mainstream
villains that people can instantly
recognize so it does make more sense to
put him central to the story as in the
original work he was a very very minor
part he was kind of a joke character
that actually took more the part in the
Catwoman spin-off so they will likely be
changing him up in several ways of
course let me know if you saw the images
and noticed anything that I didn't and
if you've seen any of their leaked
images online then be sure to drop them
below a massively hype for the movie as
I'm sure you can guess and the chase
scene looks like an awesome way to kick
start I know that movies aren't shot in
chronological order but this does sort
of seem like the way that they would
start off especially as we have a bat
bike and not Batmobile and a Selina Kyle
that is just wearing a bike helmet
overall though a massively stoked for
the work and I think it's gonna probably
be the biggest movie of next year as the
hype surrounding air is already
phenomenal it's got me excited and I
love how many little Easter eggs there
are on things even down to mining
aspects of the Batsuit 20:21 is gonna be
great and this film is definitely worth
falling for ya know so I'm sorry I
ruined that joke anyway that's
everything since the last update and I'm
very excited for the movie obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts and the
theories in this video and if you have
anything else to add then make sure you
drop them below we do breakdowns on the
Batman every week
same bat-time
same bat-channel so make sure you stay
locked heavy spoilers to never miss any
of the information if you enjoyed this
video then please give it a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our full
breakdown of some insane details you
missed in Avengers infinity war which is
gonna be linked at the end so one of the
best videos I've ever put together so
please give it a watch after this if you
want to support the channel from his
letters 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below you access
the content early and can also suggest
video topics and breakdowns we massively
appreciate it it goes a long way to
helping videos like this get made we're
gonna come chech us after the show
either follow us at Definition YT or
click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best I'll see you next
time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]